hey everybody welcome to koala zoo and
this is a planet zoo series that I'm
doing together with the old koala beach
theme from Planet coaster so please give
a warm welcome to the ladies Einar hello
and a Rudy Ren come out and actually
this time we have a completely different
guest who's never appeared on the
qawalli before but who were super
excited to work with it's Mike again you
can't escape me I am everywhere and I
might just want to add he's not even a
guest he's actually part of the team now
yes member yeah we're really happy that
you're joining us Mike yeah personally
I've been a Mike fanboy for many years
back then the roller coast Ike in three
days although I want reminisce too much
about that lest we be 10 minutes later
in the video and still not having talked
about anything ya know it's great to
have you on the team yeah that old
second three oh my goodness oh yeah yeah
stuff goes back it's good to mention
though that for some that haven't seen
our mention corrales isn't joining us
during this series he might be joining
us for an episode in a podcast or
anything like that but he's just too
busy to really commit himself to a new
qawalli series so that's why he isn't
here but hopefully we'll be able to join
us for a podcast for those who are
wondering yes and if he's listening and
watching he will want to join at some
point as a guest or whatever I'm sure
about that
I'll offer him some good point I know
there's some really awesome things that
we have planned that we've already
started kind of dreaming about it's
taken a while to get to this point but
why don't you explain silver how we got
to this architectural decision oh yeah
yeah so this is this is gonna be a bit
different from Kewanee Beach where as
qawalli Beach was
very generally Polynesian and just lots
of woodwork and thatch roofs the theme
for this one is going to be quite
radically different I'd say we were
talking in in the chats together for a
while trying to discuss what we could do
with the theme of this park and at some
points I ended up coming across some
pictures of Dutch colonial architecture
in Indonesia and we all kind of figured
that it was really cool and we wanted to
try something like it and so koala zoo
will actually be in Indonesia which is
quite a bit radically different from the
theme which used to have in Kuala beach
which was Polynesian and
hawaiian-inspired but at the same time I
think it remains very tropical the
thatched roofs might be making a
comeback as well but for now it's going
to be rather an eclectic mix of
different architectural styles and
influences that you can find in
Indonesia and the sort of South East
Asian environments around it as well so
that's also what I'm starting off with
right here to give a little bit of a
context or explanation through this
building this is the actual entrance
gates into the zoo and this was inspired
by what is part of my terrible
pronunciation apparently called a quarry
Angoon in Balinese temple architecture
which is a large gates used in temple
complexes and yeah I built this this
gate inspired by it in a sort of similar
similar style although at the same time
I also have to say a lot of this stuff
is inspired by the colonial architecture
of Indonesia and thus I'm also using
some different elements and textures
then would traditionally be used here
and I think as a Dutch guy pretending to
build buildings in Indonesia and there's
a there's some very painful political
history to please be aware of so I just
want to say that I'm doing this purely
out of sort of architectural and in
game interest and sorry about all the
things that our people have done
initially horrible Mike don't start
laughing at this part
yeah there's there some post-colonial
heritage here but this is a video game
and we are purely doing this out of a
sort of aesthetic and architectural sort
of appreciation
so it's terrible as this whole period
might have been I think there were some
cool buildings that were pretty
inspirational to do something sort of
inspired by in planets ooh so yeah the
fact is that this particular style is
actually called new Indies right yeah
yeah you can find it on Wikipedia also
is the sort of new indie style and then
there are variations of it of course
because Dutch people ended exporting a
lot of you know whatever the flavor of
the month was through Indonesia and sort
of started mixing these eventually with
local influences as well I think quite
infamously at first Dutch people really
just sort of built in Dutch ways which
ended up creating buildings which don't
really work out very well for the
climates so there's definitely some you
know changes to make these buildings a
bit more Airy with local materials and
textures etc and I think in that sense
it could almost be kind of compared to
indo-saracenic for instance which is the
British answer to melding Western and
British architecture in British India
for instance it's really that sort of
thing and in that case also much like in
those era sonic architecture this
architecture was very much reserved also
for buildings that served a sort of
colonial function so government
buildings palaces post offices anything
sort of official tended to have these
kind of colonial /local sort of blended
architectural styles yeah that was my
nerdy talk for today you guys thought
you were getting a planet Zoo video but
no you're getting a history lesson
kind of quality school for today hope
you enjoyed it and we're going to
continue with the next lesson which will
be how the hell did we not fill in the
first minutes of talking we will always
do it with self oh yeah we yeah but I
have to say so obviously our already
seen some pictures when it was finished
and it's seriously mind-blowing and I
already want to thank you for giving me
such a freaking hard challenge during
this whole collab now yes I have to
thank you too because that's really it's
really a challenge I was the most
excited about to see how you blended in
all the different pieces to create the
style you did create because honestly we
are in inverted commas we only saw the
picture but it's always a different
story to see which kind of pieces you
use and I was very excited to see that
because like from the looks of it you're
like you mmm that makes sense
yeah that looks actually good when you
go in like okay wait a second we do not
have that many pieces yet being in such
an early stage of the game so how the
hell did you do that and I'm I'm already
I'm already like oh my god I will be a
lot of search trial-and-error going on
there but I cannot wait to do this so
really that's super cool I'm also afraid
now because we also have Mike no but you
did something in my in my my zoo and it
really helped me to really get inspired
to do similar things and try different
things so I am actually really excited
to work with the three of you because
like Rudy is is super creative and like
the most crazy things so I'm gonna learn
a lot from you get you through this this
series I'm really looking forward to it
that's a good point yeah yeah that's
yeah I think that's a good thing as well
because I think we all sort of have our
own strengths I absolutely suck at
foliage and layouts of parks and things
like this which hopefully in seven we'll
be able to cover for me and Lady is the
only person in here I think who's
actually really
with animals and I think you planet Zoo
I think it'll be good to have somebody
who can actually steer us in the right
direction and making the actual zoo
that's and everything but the animals
are still gonna need good habitats we're
still gonna have to treat them well
that's got those cute animals as well so
I think we're all gonna be able to you
know bring out our strongest sort of
skill here and yeah I'm glad to at least
be sort of first with a sort of
architectural kind of episode because
for me as well to kind of bring it back
to the things that you were saying Rudy
and Lady at the end of the day you guys
can just feel free to rip off whatever
you build because that's kind of the
idea as well you know at first but ya
know really the first episode I I really
just tried to get a sense of what the
style for the rest of the park would be
you know it sort of establishes what the
park will look like in general and which
pieces can be used for the theme etc we
really wanted you to start yeah I'm
happy to do that
honestly so I think it works out that
way yeah other thing also maybe it's a
good point to talk about the setup for
the next episodes and I feel like we
have a very very good setup now because
next up will be Mike taking over and I
cannot wait to see what what you're
doing there's not that much to rip up at
this point absolutely a good thing so
after Mike will be the lady signer I
think maybe with the first animal who
knows and probably and will be my turn
to kind of go into the next direction to
kind of set sails for the second round I
guess so I think it's it's in that kind
of sense a very good layout in terms of
the personal strength we have so I can
really not wait to see that also I must
add from from what you guys just talked
about learning will be definitely one
thing but one other thing which I
recognized is a very important bit in
Planet Zoo which has
being effector in Planet Coast at all
net is stuff management I don't know how
often I freaking moved all my stuff in
my sandbox part because obviously you're
building like without this in mind but
the moment you hit the play button again
you're like oh well yeah no that doesn't
work
so don't worry I will take care of
exactly but it's super exciting to see
like if you've done so much for the
craziest habitat layout and then like
well but there has to be some kind of
snare they can't actually get to it yeah
that's gonna be super funny fine yeah I
hope that we're you know somewhere
within I know we're supposed to be in
Indonesia so I'm hoping that we can
bring in a little bit of that modern
Singapore aspect of it because I do kind
of want to have some modern exhibits to
not not all this rustic feel or all this
colonial feel true yeah yeah I think
that works out as well mm-hmm and I mean
historically it's also I mean now there
are different countries but it's very
much you know even within Indonesia you
have different cultures and you have to
sort of you going from different islands
with completely different cultures and
you know this the nation-states as an
indicator of cultures and even that's
accurate anyway so I think we can
definitely sort of widen oh it's the the
sort of cultures that we're trying to
depict here and I think also story wise
you quite often do see in these areas
like zoos or in particular parks they're
most likely build off of gardens so
basically in in you know you don't start
off with having this gate for example
for a zoo or basically sometimes it
happens but I think it's more likely to
have this kind of gate for either a park
or like a garden or maybe even like a
yeah as you said like a colonial main
building for kind of some kind of
authority or so on and then over the
time when it's not been used anymore
it's you know changed and convert it
into something else which gives us room
I guess for all the influences that we
want to want to bring in and still make
it somewhat our cohesive storyline I
guess so yeah I think the modern
buildings are well in there yeah it's
very well said so Mike are you going to
plan some Botanic Gardens that you
already look into some interesting
Gardens
types for koalas ooh well yes they are I
guess they're they're technically
exhibits because of the way that planet
zoo actually functions but definitely
for clouds force cloud weight with the
hexa cold cloud forests and gardens by
the bay in Singapore is something that
all those oh yeah I was about this thing
yeah do that that's gonna be that's
gonna be challenging I'm not gonna start
with that one I'm also gonna need a lot
more room to actually make that because
it's a huge structure but in general I
do have to do a little bit of research
on like traditional gardens in Indonesia
and see if I can find like a pattern
that we can do for a big central garden
or something like that that will be so
awesome
like a cloud gun for those of you I
think maybe potentially people don't
really know about that one like I am a
big fan of this cloud garden build you
guys have to look it up because it's
it's super impressive and yeah this is
also why you you said kind of exhibit
style which yeah I'm God I you know
building off of what you did in your
first planet botanic episode oh my god I
cannot wait to see what you're pulling
off there yeah just imagine that but
much much bigger oh yeah these buildings
are actually rotated damn it on the yes
I always thought they were like straight
and you just used a very wide angle and
slow shot I wasn't I wasn't sure because
I didn't know that sylph went that path
to be even more complicated with the
ground texture but well he didn't
eventually yeah yeah true I just wanted
to say it's it's okay I'm gonna say it
it's it's forced perspective in a sense
because the way that they fan out you
know if you stand in front of it it does
give you that idea of like a wide sort
of perspective look so it looks like you
know everything's a bit further away and
the tower in the distance is a bit
bigger so you know having these kind of
tilted to the side I think how
make the entrance feel a bit more grand
as you were walking toward it mm-hmm so
it's forced perspective but is it a
weenie yeah I would say that the the
gate is definitely a weenie yeah
attention drawing and hopefully iconic
enough it's so beautiful I still can't
help it I still can't believe that this
is implant it's you it's really
beautiful and this is the starting point
like really that is the starting point
of quality is ooh I'm super excited
because I remember on quale Beach I
haven't been part of the first few
episodes and I remember watching the
first episode like as a viewer you know
and I was like super excited about that
entrance you made back then and it was
really like the starting point and
whenever I watched this episode back
it's like well that's where everything
started and then you know one and a half
years later on a year later you see what
happened there it's crazy actually
so but it was also like really D iconic
thing of the zoo and I the park and this
is going to be exactly the same like
this is like the qawalli zoo entrance
and I don't know it has something
special and I think it's it's yeah it's
gonna be really promising for the rest
of the zoo yeah I remember seeing the
the pictures of this the the freakin
custom path there is amazing ended up
not actually going with this one because
I know I actually intended to cut this
footage out but you know might as well
keep it in now well actually he's really
short it was me messing him out with
different stone textures you know trying
to figure out if you want to make a
custom stone pavement which would be the
best thanks to us to go with but a lot
of the stone pieces in the game end up
having very rough sort of bumpy textures
that don't really work well for the the
more modern look that I was going with
so I didn't actually end up picking any
of that's unfortunately but we'll come
back to that in a minute as I think I'll
be building the actual texture at that
point yeah I think what you ended up
sitting on is actually pretty darn good
oh yes because it does give you the
give you the variation but it doesn't
look nearly as tiled but what you're
saying is you didn't do that in one go
sylph
seriously you guys can see that there
are a lot of cuts in these time lapses I
ended up spending a lot of time trying
to figure stuff out and seeing how I
wanted to do things I think just as many
unrecorded hours as recorded hours of
just trying to build stuff went into
this so people say oh you're told to
break this game because look at all the
pieces my brain is just like no it's
like one tile it's like I was okay stop
stop just counting that is what I wanted
to say like okay so it's so many pieces
in did you already break the sound I
hope can we even play in it can we even
do anything else now or is it well for
one I tried not to make the roofs too
custom so you can see a bunch of planks
on some of the roofs there but most of
the roofs will actually just be in-game
roofs I'm not doing that thing where you
put a few thousand shingles together to
make a custom roof because that's going
a bit too far but what I noticed I do
have to praise the game and that kind of
sense definitely this time because I was
super excited to see that they seem to
have changed at least one big thing
about the performance from planet
coaster yes the game does lag a bit if
you are very close to the object that
has a lot of pieces intersecting but the
moment you zoom away and you go into
another area it's completely gone you
have the old performance banks it's
actually only really located in that
area welds in and planet Cosette kind of
affected the whole park so as soon as
you hit that magic number of pieces was
like yeah well have fun now I guess but
you know with this game that's a lot
better I mean I experienced that I know
what a few things where I got a custom
roof done and yeah at the end it was
really still a very good performance so
I'm very happy about that
yeah I agree with that that's I have a
pretty big park right
and it still runs mostly the same as a
when it started like there were some
performance issues during the way but
with updates and stuff it has been fixed
a lot of time so I think performance
rise like FPS wise it's it's really
running running still perfectly fine
yeah and it says what for me at least it
has way way less legs and kind of frame
drops whilst I had so many frame drops
in in larger parks and plans to it I
don't really have them at all and I
basically I still run my Yosemite zoo
over 100 FPS which is I mean still crazy
yeah then again you have a beast of a PC
well only the graphics are to be honest
and I'm like I still run sixteen
gigabytes of RAM only so oh wow
and uh well I got a good eye seven but I
found not the best one I think it's it
dropped down in the ratings to below 20
or whatever so well I don't I don't mind
it's good enough but I think it's not as
beasty as it could be so may I may I
just say about this logo my god if it
really looks like you're such a pro with
me right this is maybe not entirely what
it looks like so I am NOT an architect
as some people like to think but I I do
I do a master in urban studies so I go
to school with a lot of architects so I
had architect paper on hand and we had a
logo for a koala zoo which was remade
from the koala beach logo by Rudy thank
you very much very nice and yeah
basically what I ended up doing is
copying it over to a sheet of
architecture paper and clipping that to
my computer screen and you could
actually just it's super translucent you
could just see through it but at the
same time you see the the quality Beach
logo kamalii zoo logo that I so I'm just
copying that over through the paper over
here so while it looks super impressive
it's still pretty impressive I mean
doing any sort of or shape logos is
always fascinating to me yeah I mean
this is the L ride you guys couldn't
have chosen a more difficult font to
work with well actually we didn't choose
the font that's a mistake and I can I
was searching for a lot of different
styles of the set and anything else I
tried was even worse like honestly
everything else that's right was really
going to be the rest room logo far back
yeah but from now from now on it's still
easy guys it's not an L for anyone
watching if you dare to comment it's
enough please know if you need to take
video tackett quality loop because
that's what you know Mike how many
comments I still get about the mail so
many people keep commenting about it I
love your mail I mean you know people
don't forget I mean this is also why
we're building in a Mexican theme right
[Music]
what is the new theme do you remember
your Mexican Mexican so we're doing the
new Mexican style
why isn't qawalli su Mexican themed I
kind of is I ended up using a lot of
Mexican scenery pieces in this value so
we have maximum
Oh gotcha no I think Mike totally missed
at least one because he was busy doing
Gardens I'm everybody else's projects
[Laughter]
well Rudy I don't get mad but I'm still
gonna feel I'm still gonna feel my kin
so yeah during games come when we were
getting early access to the game
basically that was yeah that was not yet
revealed which is the Indian scenery
Rudy asked if it was the Mexican scenery
later on we were watching the footage
and we were creating our videos because
the embargo was like a week later and I
was texting Rudy like Rudy Rudy do you
remember what kind of theme it was what
was it called yeah was Mexican we've
both made a video but I only mentioned
it in a video but I didn't make a video
about the theme but really made a video
which I never even got this oh my god
and Shaw was like I'm pretty sure this
is the Union theme guys our videos just
went live thank you
I mean I got a new emote I got like 20
people sobbing with the hint I'm Mexican
I cannot complain still want to say that
it just was down to all the hype and I
was like still when lady asked I was
like looking at the footage and cutting
several things I'm at like 20 videos
whatever and I was looking at the the
colourful buildings no like yeah clearly
Mexican right I was like okay I did not
think a second about the fact that all
the animals in there were clearly Indian
related Indian Rhino for example of the
Indian elephant in Mexico didn't see the
elephants no but we did well we heard
welcome back to three Europeans that an
American talk about other cultures I was
just about to say you know I understand
why you guys were so eager to let me
tackle the architectures maybe they
would have liked to have a Mexican
quality zoo I don't know well at least I
I personally do have the theme in game
you don't so I should have just just
saying I feel like the climate is
actually pretty similar honestly yeah
well yeah probably yeah you just drink
tequila and that's what is the national
drink of Indonesia no idea colonial
crossover I was actually thinking do we
like we have complete freedom what
animals we will add right it's not like
we're building an Asian theme so we're
mostly gonna get the Asian animals like
we don't have Indonesian animals right
from that area no it's not is it
Noah Zoot generally is not really about
the native animals anyway usually a
rescue is about that's true a lot of
people are like okay I'm gonna build a
North American theme so I'm gonna use
those animals mostly I did an Asian
themed one so I decided to get mostly
Asian themed and then African part but
we just have complete freedom I like
that
because you know I will be probably the
one mostly adding animals here including
Rudy hey animals are easier than rides
right kind of yeah oh yeah definitely
definitely it's so different
playing in planets to compare it to a
planet coaster although I do have to say
I really sometimes really missed a
fantasy stuff with me the more I play
planet is soo the more I think I would
love to build a castle here
I'm not gonna build a caste or implant
issue so yeah that's the only thing I'm
like maybe I will get back to planet
coaster one day again I mean I feel like
you can still do that I was watching GA
you Ray I don't know how you say it
exactly but his Alice was was pretty
damn awesome yeah that's awesome and
that's also really cool because it's a
it's a recreation of Sean Boone in in
Vienna which is a really cool zoo
because it's located in an old palace
like an old Palace Gardens
oh that's also why he's making the
palace right now and he's gonna you know
add a zoo to it later shout-out to you
too by the way I'll link his YouTube
channel in the description yes now came
out with a video on the palace and it's
super cool but yeah it's kind of it's
it's a really cool concept for a zoo
I've always thought you know just taking
these old palace gardens which aren't
used anymore and converting them into
into zoo including all of this really
cool classical architecture I think it's
really smart I think is just really
smart from a from having the land and
trying to make use of it and to do
something with it because those gardens
can be huge
oh yeah yeah I'm really gonna check his
video out once we're done with recording
because I'm really excited to see what
he's made I love this building I think I
love it even more than the the big gate
just because I like this kind of
colonial architecture I can't so really
today's with the orange brick I love it
yeah it's a little bit Dutch I'll give
it some explanation so basically this
was mostly inspired by the buildings
that you can find in the old city centre
of Jakarta or in bundle which feature
very Dutch like buildings with the
typical orange red ish Dutch tile roofs
but then they have white plaster walls
and other you know detailing and the use
of materials than Dutch buildings of
course so I think that's a really
interesting contrast so for this
building
I was generally inspired by that but
also the Dutch Swiss Chalet style
architecture which features a lot of
woodwork
and decorations around the roofs so
that's why I'm putting all of this roof
around all of this wood around the roof
and creating these custom cables and
stuff was really cool too is that in
some of the resource materials you were
showing is that some of these Dutch
buildings were painted really like
tropical colors and kind of intense so
it gave you this feeling like oh yeah no
I think I know that from somewhere yeah
right it's it's interesting how some of
this colonial architecture just kind of
ends up being pretty much just Dutch
architecture but with a different color
scheme mm-hmm so I think that's what
this kind of is as well it reminds me
it's high any bit of the efteling as
well because I know the efteling likes
the chalets as well you see a lot of
these kinds of decorated wooden Gables
and little spires everywhere so so what
was this building again for what did you
add in this building so I'm actually not
really fleshing out much of these
buildings I think mike is gonna have to
yeah this is so this is gonna be the
sort of like information guest Services
Building so this is where you could buy
tickets or also just get Maps or extra
information or can people get a refund
[Laughter]
or yeah I don't know maybe maybe if
you're if you're a group of people who
are allowed to have a backstage tour and
then this is the kind of building that
you show up I don't know at a theme park
that is that it's what I am the kind of
person who shows up to this buildings
for I really love that sorry I just
needed to flex yeah but this is honestly
super amazing this building is when you
when you were actually talking about
this color scheme and stuff I did a lot
of research when I was doing is Lana
Poli and I found this super interesting
like what kind of color schemes do work
with the Sun best and and why they keep
cool on whatever so this is pretty
interesting to take into account because
you just said okay it's like you know
architecture wise it is like that
architecture and then mixed up with
different colors however there's also a
slight change about the roofs the roofs
have to be at a slightly different angle
to just work a bit better with more
heavy rain so this is also kind of
something they used to do a bit so that
the angles um make it easier obviously
for the water to go down and they stand
out a little bit further so that the
water doesn't go down the wall to make
sure that you know the wall is not
always so wet the woodwork doesn't get
covered in exactly this is why only
going little bit outwards and then they
usually do so I found this interesting
because you did did this actually on
this build here so it's pretty cool to
see that and I am really a huge fan of
these little bits and things you just
look at any of you you see you know it
feels right but when you think about it
actually has a reason so it's actually
cool yeah thanks I didn't even think
about the rain sort of argument there
but now in hindsight oh my goodness yes
that in some cinematic footage yeah
that's a good point
Dutch Chalet is that what this
architecture was so technically it's
called the shallots tell in in Dutch but
it's based on Swiss Chalet style
architecture so and it's interesting
because Swiss Chalet style architecture
in turn at least I've read in some
random PDF that I went through a few
days ago that it's it's similar to
Nepalese architecture of all things okay
which you can see has very similar
overhanging roofs and wooden beams
upholding them etc which just sort of
comes from this kind of mountain like
architecture so it's like you've got the
Nepalese infra influence to Switzerland
to the Netherlands and finally exporting
it all the way back to Indonesia so yeah
it's an interesting blend here mm-hmm
it's like really a box of possibilities
and and ideas and stuff that comes to my
mind god
I'm I don't it will be so hard to hold
back until fourth episode I really have
to contain myself playing around with
yeah I'm really excited really excited
for just this whole collab in general we
have been talking about this for four
months already as soon as we knew that
planet it would come out we were like
call the zoo the zoo like everyone was
asking maybe maybe while we already
spoke about that like the first day sure
I have to say I'm pretty proud of us
like none of us was actually even
hinting at it we were like oh well hmm I
don't know you know if so maybe but we
didn't even tech someone or just you you
know little hints or whatever until that
day where we posted the video well
actually Lady United but yeah but it's
good because now we have Mike and Mike
is like the best addition for the for
our series like really I'm super excited
that you're joining I am too everyone
definitely go and follow Mike because
he's the one that is going to blow you
away in the second episode it's a
win-win situation for us if you don't
blow us away well it's your fault and if
you do it's perfect I'm just gonna get
wrong feedback then
[Laughter]
so anyway I'm gonna leave you guys with
some cinematic shots now and I'd like to
thank everybody here for watching and of
course the whole qawalli team for being
here with me for this amazing commentary
today
since a little bit of sarcasm there but
alright I wasn't perfect one taker so I
don't know what you're talking about yes
that's all we do we do one take here and
we just pray that no awkward moments end
up happening with you anyway but that's
life you know you gotta take it I'm
gonna take everything including the
awkward moments yeah anyway I'm stalling
on these and people are watching this
like I'll just get it over with
yeah all right well anyway thanks again
for watching everybody and I hope to see
you all in the next episode of quality
sooo on Mike's channel that's right bye
guys
[Music]
[Music]